so number one is empathy right which is
we don't always know why someone is
underperforming
um and we we're all we're all guilty of
it which is being judgmental right
um they're stupid they're lazy they're
unmotivated they don't care you know
what what whatever it is they're weak
you know that we go through the list and
the problems we're going to treat them
that way based on our whatever narrative
we have in our mind and empathy is
really about replacing judgment with
curiosity which is yes it is entirely
true they may be lazy or unmody all of
that is possible but um to express
curiosity to express empathy are you
okay your performance is down are you
okay and hopefully the the hard work of
leadership has already been done
where an environment exists that that
person feels psychologically safe enough
to say what's going on I made a mistake
I'm afraid
I don't feel like I have the training to
do the job you're asking me to do
I'm having trouble at home with my
family it's affecting my work
um I'm stressed you know I'm afraid I'm
scared like I need help all of these
things are very very difficult for
someone to say for fear that they will
be seen as weak
um and the reality is it takes
tremendous courage to say I need help
and the reality is we all need help no
one is perfect at everything so to spend
your day lying hiding and faking
pretending that you're great at
everything something is going to break
because it is it is literally fake so it
starts it starts with empathy it starts
with somebody whether they're in a
leadership position or they they act
like a leader in the team to take that
person aside in a in a safe space in a
private space and be like dude you know
something's different something's wrong
what you know what's going on yeah I
think that's that's great I think I'm
glad you brought up the word empathy
because I've heard you a little talk
about empathy I think it's empathy and
perspective or two words yeah you've
used a number of times and how they kind
of play together can you talk a little
bit about that how they play together as
a leader well I think
what I said just some moments ago which
is replacing judgment with curiosity
which is it by having curiosity it
widens your aperture
and um and uh a narrative is very very
dangerous
um we see what happens when somebody has
a narrative a fixed narrative and we we
see it at a population level you know
that certain populations in our nation
have a narrative about who you are and
the kind of person you are the way that
you view the world simply because you
wear a badge and they will treat you
that way because of your Nar their
narrative now cops carry narratives as
well their narrative about uh about a
community affects how they may treat a
community and so narrative is super
dangerous and we have narratives about
each other at work you know the minute
leadership and again we're all guilty of
it you know we're all guilty of our
little bubbles you know our little Echo
Chambers and you know leadership sucks
they don't know what they're doing okay
well that now becomes a narrative and
guess how they're going to act every
time leadership says hey I need
something right we do it as well like
that person's lazy that becomes a
narrative